si alice se rend au musée aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas seulement pour contempler
tableaux et sculptures elle a rendez
vous pour donner son sang
entouré d'hommes oeuvre des 16e et 17e
siècles cette passionnée d'art admire le
décor exceptionnel de la salle richelieu
c'est vrai que je l'avais vu déjà il ya
un an et j'avais adoré cette salle
c'était vraiment la salle du musée que
je préférais et la revoir autrement
finalement dans un cadre un peu plus
médical mais sa fin ça change tout
vraiment c on est détendu on sent bien
au milieu des oeuvres d'art c'est c'est
magique comme elle de nombreuses heures
les années ont sauté sur l'occasion pour
faire une bonne action dans ce lieu
insolite
c'est simple lumière tamisée
cadre artistique c'est ça change des
salles des fêtes je suis venu avec
plusieurs de mes collègues ses tics
on s'est dit que ça allait 2 sympa de
venir ici de voir les oeuvres et ouais
mon bien pendant votre pause déjeuner
après or pour bosser donner son sang
dans les musées c'est une idée qui a
germé durant les différents confinement
inspiré par l'initiative strasbourgeoise
le musée des beaux-arts d'orléans a
répondu aux besoins de l'établissement
français du sang offrir un grand espace
au coeur de la ville pour effectuer des
collectes
je pense que le fait que le rendez vous
soit cette fois ci dans les musées
surtout dans la période que nous avons
traversées liés une opération qui permet
de donner de soi avec une finalement une
rendez vous culturel a donné envie
peut-être même à de nouveaux donneurs de
s'inscrire de venir découvrir ces
rendez-vous et de nouveaux donneurs il
en faut pas moins de dix mille dons de
sang par jour sont nécessaires pour
subvenir aux besoins des malades en
france et pour une fois le musée ne
demandent pas de passe sanitaire une
seule recommandation pour les personnes
ayant contracté la copie de 19 ans
attend de quinze jours après la guérison
après avoir vu un test pcr négatif et on
n'a pas besoin de passes sanitaires pour
venir donner du sens puisque le bearish
n'est pas transmis
la collecte sera renouvelée chaque
premier lundi du mois dans une salle
différente
en octobre les donneurs pour en changer
de décor direction l'italie du 17 heures